in Germany a suspected coup plot is
foiled more than 3 000 officers
targeting suspects of a far-right group
accused of planning to overthrow the
government
it's alleged they wanted to storm the
German Parliament and seize power
military are united by the hatred of
democracy of our state and of people who
stand up for our community that is why
we are taking action against them with
all the force of the law
among the 25 detained a judge and former
member of the right-wing afd party the
group is believed to have around 50
members some former military
this Aristocrat Prince Heinrich the 13th
is alleged to have been lined up as the
new leader prosecutors said he contacted
Russian officials with the aim of
negotiating a new order the kremlins
denied any involvement
officials here say the group was
planning a violent attack right at the
heart of government here as well as
wanting to build a new Army some of the
members were inspired by Deep state
conspiracy theories from Q Anon and
Germany's reichsberger movement
one of them experts say today's arrests
are proof of how seriously the
authorities are taking the far-right
threat it's a terrorist attempt
by an ideology that says okay this whole
democracy is a deep State it's
controlled by Foreign forces
and we have to attack it and to overcome
it
and this implies violence
150
Germany Austria and Italy an alleged
terrorist Network targeting democracy in
Europe today disrupted Siobhan Robbins
Sky News Berlin